so my best friend brooke and i decided  that we were gonna facetime men that  i've matched with on dating apps over  the last couple months and these weren't  just guys i've been talking to like a  lot of these guys i haven't talked to in  months like this guy the last time i  talked to him was may so i'm gonna have  brooke rank the conversations on a scale  of one to ten that we had with them  so at first this guy was a two  he picked up and he looked very scared i  got scared i thought we caught him doing  something a little weird so that was  that was interesting but he called back  later and i would say it went up to his  six only because he answered and talked  to us in his closet so a little weird  but the combo was good so